So, we have seen how we can use the present to talk about the future in Spanish using voy a, vamos  a, or using some future context
(pronto- soon, mañana- tomorrow, la semana que viene- the  week that comes- next week).
But we can also use the present in Spanish to talk about the past,
just as we can in English.
In English and in Spanish we have three ways to talk about the past, or three main ways to talk about the past.
We can say, for example: I ate.
We can say: I was eating.
And we can say: I have eaten.
Now, when we say I have eaten, we are using I have, which is the present,
and then eaten is like a version of the verb which is kind of complicated in English.
You say I have eaten, I have gone, I  have wanted.
Wanted, eaten, gone, they are all very different.
So that is kind of complicated in English, how to build that.
But in Spanish it is very simple.
So, we have: I ate, I was eating, and I have eaten.
This I have eaten is going to be the first past that we learn.
And we are actually using the present.
Now, this have is not tener.
Tener we use for possession, and we use with the combination of que to give this meaning of "have to".
Now, the verb that we use for have in the sense of I have eaten, I have gone, in Spanish it's haber.
Haber: h-a-b-e-r. And of course we have the silent h there, in haber.
Haber is to have in the sense of I have eaten. But haber is extremely irregular,
there is no “habo”,
it is extremely irregular.
But there is a very easy way we can remember all of the versions of haber, even though it is very irregular.
What are the two vowel sounds that we have inside of the verb haber?
/a/ and /e/.
Good,
we have /a/ and /e/ inside the word haber, and we are going to use that to help us remember the versions.
Let's start with he.
He. All by itself, it means I have.
It is spelled h-e.
And of course, we have the silent h there from haber in he (h-e).
I have.
We actually saw already one other verb that forms its I version in this way.
What was to know?
Saber.
And I know is?
Sé.
I have from haber is spelled h-e,
just like sé from saber is spelled s-e.
They are the only two verbs that form the I version in this way, in this very irregular way.
So you get sé from saber, and you get he from haber.
Different from saber, all of the versions of haber are irregular.
Now, I and we are connected.
We can see how we is the plural of I.
I, and then when I include you and I say we, it is like the plural of I.
So, I and we are connected.
So, just knowing that, if you had to guess what is we have,
knowing that I have is he,
what do you think you would guess?
Hes?
This works with nouns and adjectives.
So, it is a very good example of why, whilst we are avoiding grammatical terminology, we want to know what type of word we are dealing with, because different words behave in different ways.
Nouns, words you can put the or a in front of: la semana,  una semana- the week, a week; and adjectives, words that describe, that you can put is in front of: is red, is tall:
these words use -s for plural. But we have never seen the verb do that, have we?
What does the verb use for we?
-amos.
Or?
-emos.
-imos.
And what do they have in common,
-amos, -emos, -imos?
The -mos.
Good,
ok.
So if he is I have (h-e), how do you think it might be we have?
Hemos.
Good.
So, from haber you get he and hemos,
no?
And we don't want to memorise this,
we said we can think just this thought,
just the thought
"What vowels do we have in haber?
/a/ and /e/.
Ok: he.
He by itself is I, it is connected to we: he and hemos."
Now we go to the other vowel
/a/.
H-a
all by itself
ha means
she has, it has, he has, you (formal) have.
Now I am sure you can tell me the rest of them.
What are the other versions?
What is they have?
Han.
Good.
So, we start with this base of he and ha, and we can remember that just by looking at the vowels that are inside haber. And then, we can add on what we need.
So, we have he for I have, hemos for we have, we have ha (h-a) for he/she/it/you (formal) have or has,
you added an -n and what did you get?
Han.
And what does that mean?
They have.
Or?
You guys have.
Good.
And how would you say you have informally?
Has.
Good.
And that is your set:
he-hemos, ha-has-han.
So you have two key vowel sounds /e/ and /a/.
He-hemos for I and for we (for I and the plural of I which is we).
And then you have ha for he-she-it, han for they, has for you (informal).
Now we need to learn how to make eaten, how to make gone, how to make wanted,
if we want to say I have eaten, I have gone, I have wanted.
This is very simple in Spanish.
-ar verbs will lose their -ar, they will lose their final -ar, and they will put -ado on the end.
So for example, we have to speak which is hablar.
If you want to build spoken, you take off that -ar and you put on -ado.
Hablado.
Now we can speak about the past.
Now we can say I have spoken,
and we need to think about the two bits separately.
I have spoken:
Is it he? He hablado.
Very good.
He hablado.
I haven't spoken.
Where do you think the no is going
I haven't  spoken:
In the beginning.
No he hablado.
Very good.
I haven't spoken.
We have spoken?
Hemos hablado.
Hemos hablado. He has spoken:
Ha hablado.
Good.
She has spoken?
Ha hablado.
Good.
They?
Han hablado.
You (informal)?
Has hablado.
Perfect,
well done.
Now, this is actually more useful, this past, than what you might think it is, because this is used
even more in Spanish than it is in English.
So maybe you want the past I spoke,
but you can use, for now, I have spoken.
This "have past" is very popular
and used much more than in English.
So, how would you say anticipation?
Anticipación.
Good,
and to anticipate?
Anticipar.
Good.
How would you say we have anticipated it?
So, there is a few things you have to think about.
Think about them separately, then put them together.
We have anticipated it.
So, to get anticipated you take away the -ar, and you put -ado.
Ah! Yes.
Hemos anticipado lo.
And where does that lo go? Because anticipado is not like-
Ah! It has changed now, so it is in the beginning.
Yes.
So, lo
hemos anticipado.
Good.
Lo hemos anticipado.
The word for for, like in time, we have anticipated it for a long time for example, is por.
Por.
You might know por favor, which means please in Spanish. Which means "for a favour".
Por favor, "for a favour".
So this por is also for, in the sense of "for periods of time."
So, if you want to say we have anticipated it for a long time, we will just say we have anticipated it for much time.
maybe there are some bits in there that you think you don't know. But we will see when we get to them.
So, the first bit is we have anticipated it.
Lo hemos anticipado.
Good.
For: Por. A lot or much:
Mucho.
Time.
We saw briefly before that we have a word in English that we use for time, that we only use with music.
What was that word?
Tempo.
And how did it change in Spanish?
Tiempo?
Tiempo, yes! The e split.
So: we have anticipated it for a long time.
Good.
Lo hemos anticipado por mucho tiempo.
Very good.
Maybe you want to ask somebody Did you celebrate?
And you think "oh, I don't know did yet in Spanish".
You can just say: Have  you celebrated?
And that is fine.
Like I said, it is used even more in Spanish than in English.
So, some certain situations it might sound a little bit uncomfortable the translation into English.
But in Spanish, most of the time, it is going to be fine.
So, have you celebrated?
Let’s speak informally.
Has – celebración... celebrar... celebrado.
Good,
good.
So, ¿has celebrado?
Good,
¿has celebrado?
Haven't you celebrated?
¿No has celebrado?
Why haven't you celebrated?
Good.
What was the word for where?
Dónde.
Where have you celebrated?
¿Dónde has celebrado?
Good.
Where have you celebrated it?
¿Dónde lo has celebrado?
Good.
So, -ar verbs, we take away the -ar and we put -ado. And we get this version of the verb that we need after haber, which in English has many different forms.
Like I said: you have gone,  wanted, eaten... it changes a lot.
But in Spanish we get rid of the -ar and we put -ado.
We said that to take,
and also sometimes to drink, is tomar.
Tomar.
So how would you say I have taken?
He tomado.
Good.
We have taken:
Hemos tomado.
Good. Has she taken it? Has she taken it?
Has she taken it?
¿Han lo tomado?
That is a guess,
you are looking at me like it is a guess
I want you to establish your own thought process of how you are going to find it.
So what is the first bit you need to think about?
Has she  taken it?
Has she.
Good.
What is that?
Ok, so it is he and hemos for I and we.
Yes.
So it is.. oh! It is ha! It is just ha. Yes. So, has she taken it?
¿Lo ha tomado?
Sometimes I am going to build you up step by step,
sometimes I am just going to give you the sentence and you need to deconstruct what thoughts you need to have first,
and to divide it up into various thoughts to get the sentence, resisting any temptation to guess or to say something that we are not sure of.
You can be sure and be wrong,
there is no problem there,
But we want to think about it, dividing the sentence up into each individual thing we need to think about.
First, she has, ha.
She has taken, ha tomado.
She has taken it.
It is lo,
where do I put the lo? Before the changed verb.
Lo ha tomado.